i changed the way that my thumbnails
looked i was looking at my competitors
and like oh their their thumbnails look
like this my thumbnails got to look like
this now i was just changing everything
left right front and center
and then when i actually spent the time
to look at my data i was like wait a
second the thumbnails that i had two
years ago that i created on canva
actually had a higher click-through rate
than the thumbnails that i spend fifty
dollars per thumbnail on on like fancy
graphic designers on
can your youtube channel break when no
one's watching or the videos just aren't
performing anymore has youtube stopped
working we're gonna be breaking that
down and so much more in today's episode
with our friend and fellow youtube
creator vanessa lowan she talks about
the experience she just went through
when her youtube channel stopped working
my name is heather torres and i'm the
host of the think media podcast the
number one podcast to help you grow your
influence on youtube and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
profit online business today's episode
is brought to you by our think
mediasale.com
this is a fabulous sale that you need to
know about right now we have over 80
percent off of our brand new course and
bundle the youtube made simple course
and all of the bonuses that go with it
you're going to learn how to get your
first 1000 subscribers and earn your
first 1 000 on youtube how to do it
without a fancy camera editing
experience or working 50 hours a week on
your youtube channel we're breaking
through the mindsets that are holding
you back from being confident on camera
and you're gonna learn how to film edit
and upload your videos plus our fast
acting strategies to help you gain those
subscribers quickly you can get all the
information for this amazing sale that
we have during the holidays at
thinkmediasale.com now i'm so excited to
bring you vanessa lau she is an amazing
content creator here on youtube who is
growing a thriving multiple seven-figure
online business she started working in a
corporate job that she hated and really
wanted to become a content creator who
could help other people she went through
a journey of getting to that and she
shares all about that over on her
youtube channel and recently she
actually had to make a pivot on her
channel because it stopped working in
this episode sean and vanessa sit down
and talk about what happened and how she
learned from it and what you can learn
if your youtube channel is experiencing
the same thing
[Music]
you made a video titled
i messed up my
youtube channel and i think a lot of
people can relate to this like am i
messing up my youtube channel man i've
had these great videos in the past now
it seems like they're not working what
am i doing wrong so when you made that
video can you tell us what happened and
what did you learn
yeah i'll kind of explain what triggered
me to create that video and then i'll
share what i learned so what really
triggered it was i was spending a lot of
money
and time on my youtube channel more than
i ever did before in the past but i
didn't feel like i was getting the
payoff that matched the amount of
investment that i was pouring into so
for example the views the view duration
everything all of my stats when you open
up the new creator studio you see it
basically tells you how you're doing and
everything was like arrows down in the
red and i'm like what is going on here
so that's what prompted me to kind of
dig a little bit deeper because uh i
just started seeing reds all across the
board that i'd never seen before but
personally for me it felt like i was
doubling my work doubling my expenses
trying to keep my youtube channel
running
and so that's what happened and here's
essentially what i learned from my
experience of just diving into the
actual analytics because i feel like one
of the main takeaways of that video that
i created about how i messed up my
youtube channel was it almost felt like
i spent more
energy and time
on the wrong things so a good example is
i spent way more time
refining the editing
hiring video editors um clean like
changing the thumbnails doing all the
fancy things than i actually did about
looking at the analytics and
creating better content in general and
so that's when i realized like okay
like these videos yeah they're fancier
the the equipment is better
the audio is clearer
all those things but the views are
pretty much the same that i got last
year or the two the year before that
when i started my channel and i was
filming videos at my mom's bedroom
it was it was insane to see that and my
takeaway was like overly produced videos
don't actually get you more views
you can check to see if it gets you more
average view duration but it didn't for
me and so that's when i realized there's
that kind of tipping point where you
kind of spend
you kind of like spend too much on the
equipment and you spend too much on you
know editing you have to realize that at
the heart of it can people see you
can people hear you
does the message come across is the
video engaging in itself if yes that's
enough
you don't have to pour thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars on
your youtube channel i think that's
where i kind of like went in over my
head and thought that that's what i
needed to get to the next level when it
wasn't true at all
so that's the number one lesson the
second lesson was
don't fix what's not broken and this is
where i really started to lead my
youtube channel with a lot of feelings
and not necessarily all facts i think as
a creator it's hard though because we're
such creative people and we have so many
ideas and you know most creators i know
don't want to stay in one spot and they
want to like do a bunch of things we're
multi-passionate
and so i kind of let that get the best
of me too because i usually am someone
that's very into the data but for some
reason maybe because the views were
getting lower and lower
i felt like panic and i felt like
throwing spaghetti at my um channel
trying to make everything work
while also ignoring the things that were
hurting me which was the low channel
stats it was very clear that everything
was going down but i just didn't want to
believe it and i didn't want to actually
look into it because it was painful to
look into it it was embarrassing it kind
of hurt my ego a little bit and so what
i ended up doing was just okay well i
just got to change the thumbnail and
make it like change the font here or oh
let me just hire a new video editor and
i'll fix things overnight i was doing
the easy fixes
but not the hard work of actually
looking into things so what ended up
happening
was on the topic of thumbnails i changed
the way that my thumbnails looked i was
looking at my competitors and like oh
their their thumbnails look like this my
thumbnails got to look like this now i
was just changing everything left right
front and center
and then when i actually spent the time
to look at my data i was like wait a
second the thumbnails that i had two
years ago that i created on canva
actually had a higher click-through rate
than the thumbnails that i spend fifty
dollars per thumbnail on on like fancy
graphic designers on
imagine how i felt
when i saw that data i was like
and the funny thing is that it wasn't
even me that looked at the data it was
my social media manager
that was like hey vanessa i just like
compiled the stats these are our top
like top 10 performing thumbnails and
when she actually took the screenshot of
it
all those thumbnails were the old
thumbnails and i was like wow
the last year i kept changing things up
and turns out that it wasn't actually
performing
and then the third um the third takeaway
and this one actually i didn't mention
on the video but i think it was like
something i learned after i filmed the
video so this is like exclusive content
here on the podcast and that was i think
a turning point was when i launched my
podcast
and i put everything in one channel
and the reason where i think i messed up
there is i thought that okay you know
what i already have this channel that
has so many subscribers i can throw
anything at it and it'll do well um and
so when i launch the podcast
i wanted to do a video format of it and
instead of creating a separate channel
for it i put it all in one place and
what i didn't realize at the time was
wait a second the podcast content
is pretty different from my regular
youtube videos
the audience that i'm trying to attract
with my podcast is also very different
from the type of audience that i have on
my youtube
and so that ended up
kind of creating a situation where my
loyal and existing subscribers were
confused about the new content
and because it didn't necessarily
meet what they're usually used to or
what they were interested in they
stopped clicking on the videos on the
for the podcast and then what ended up
happening was the click-through rate
started going down and what i learned
from my experience is this is where
algorithms come into play
basically because the youtube channel
the youtube videos were kind of pulling
the stats down
everything kind of went down across the
board and it almost felt like my videos
just kind of stopped getting recommended
to my typical audience so that is
something that i didn't put in the video
but definitely
um was a huge learning lesson from me
and that's what i admire you um i marry
a lot about you sean is you're very good
with you have like multiple channels
you're splitting up your content um to
different channels to different people
and i think that's um that's a very
smart move that i didn't rookie mistake
on my end
well there's so many insights there and
i'm excited to unpack this um but the
couple recap was the big idea of overly
produced content doesn't necessarily
cause things to grow and maybe people
could relate um sometimes to that
rawness of youtube i think there's kind
of a fine line youtube is its own
ecosystem it's not netflix it's not hbo
max it's not hollywood
it is a place where we can authentically
connect with people and of course people
go viral sometimes telling just a story
time video or a video from their
smartphone where they just really pour
out their heart
and we've had the same challenge of
course at think media as time goes on we
have more opportunity because we have
more resources so we have the latest
gear
things go from you know 1080p 60 to 4k
30 to 4k 60 maybe 8k is the next thing
better lenses better dynamic range but
it's like is that really going to be the
game changer i think we know it's not
content value is infinitely more
important than production value
um that also sometimes we can be led
intuition wise and i know i do that
sometimes we just feel something this is
a good business principle that being an
intuitive entrepreneur is almost
necessary for survival when you're
starting but eventually you have to
become data driven and your intuition
could be wrong so like i think i want to
go this direction with my thumbnails it
might work it might not and so being
data driven could be a great uh is a
great example there
but you mentioned a couple other tips as
well you also mentioned being over
batched and i think we fall into those
that trap here at think media
not that it's a trap it's a
leverage tool it's a family and
lifestyle tool to shoot as many videos
as possible to get as far ahead as
possible but you mentioned a couple
nuances with a not being able to react
in real time or even energy what did you
learn from maybe
how far ahead do you try to get when
batch what is batching videos if maybe
someone's hearing that time for the uh
that term for the first time and uh what
did you learn and from being over
batched
yeah thanks for reminding me that i even
mentioned that in the video i completely
forgot about it but um what batching
means is essentially in one sitting or
in one time frame you kind of film all
of the videos at once so for example
maybe instead of chasing your tail
filming one video a week if you're
uploading once a week maybe in one
sitting in one week you film four of
them so now you've got a whole month's
worth of content and you don't
necessarily have to film every single
week until the next batch and so that's
what batching means and so
i have been on a journey with finding
what works for me
and um what happened was i thought okay
well i'm quite busy i was going through
a move i was doing a lot of things so i
was like you know what let me just batch
everything let me not just batch one
month's worth of content let me batch
like three to four months worth of
content so i went hard with everything
in one go and i thought that that was
going to be the best thing that's ever
happened to me
but eventually what i realized as i was
scheduling out the content that i
batched months ago was number one
i wasn't able to react to feedback so at
the same time that i did batch those
videos but even if it wasn't the case i
had actually
changed video editors and so that wasn't
the right season for me to over batch
that much especially as i was still
testing new video editors new content
ideas new style new things um and so but
because all those videos were already
edited
and especially if you have a team you've
already paid for it you know invoice
sent paid all the good and good done
it's hard to go back and change things
and so it was a very frustrating
experience during those three months
just watching my
batch content come out and seeing the
audience say hey vanessa like i don't
like how this was edited or like hey um
this was a little bit distracting in the
video or hey the sound wasn't that clear
here or
hey can you actually elaborate more on
this concept in a future video
you know because everything was kind of
set in stone couldn't really make those
changes and over time i felt that some
of my more loyal subscribers were
getting frustrated because they didn't
they felt like i wasn't listening
but i was i just couldn't actually react
to it fast enough
not only this during that time period i
talk a lot about instagram on my
specific channel
and during that time instagram reels was
really taken off
and i couldn't really like react to all
the trends that were happening in social
media fast enough because i already had
a schedule that
was set out with all of my content
needing to come out and everything like
that so it just felt very frustrating
and what i learned from that experience
is that batching is still a really great
strategy i still don't stand by you know
chasing your tail every single week i
think that just leads to burnout but at
the same time you shouldn't batch a
whole year's worth of content in one go
because so much can change in that time
frame your audience will have certain
questions certain demands certain
feedback and you do want to leave some
space to be reactive to it so what i do
now is i maybe maybe batch like one
month's worth of content
instead of three let's say unless
there's a life circumstance or a
business thing that pops up and i do
need to kind of plan around that
and if i were to add also just being
okay with going off schedule okay like
if there's really a trend if i really
think about it there was nothing really
stopping me from actually turning on the
camera filming it and just
getting that edited and uploaded and
just sacrificing maybe the schedule i
think that would have been fine as well
but at the time i didn't really think of
doing that and i was just like you know
what everything is set in stone can't
make any changes but if i'm really
honest with myself that's not a hundred
percent true
well when we learned three
uh i agree with you on the over batching
and we have kind of three approaches
that we've been applying to our video
podcast channel the think media podcast
because we're actually batched three
months ahead now
um but the way we're solving that is a
couple things one
we're actually just batching the core
content and because i have a co-host
heather taurus she can do a quick tip or
even what the call to actions are based
on our marketing calendar or whatever it
is that is actually only shot about one
month at a time additionally to your
point we are um going to some weeks have
double uploads and so podcast listeners
not just on the video side but the audio
side we basically have kind of if you
will core curriculum that's more
evergreen that comes out every tuesday
um and then when we need to react we
want to do exactly what you said there's
no reason why we can't maybe give
another upload or jump on something
that's a little more fresh and we
recognize that and even we're really
listening to your advice like man being
overbatched we need to actually be make
a concerted effort to be able to react
in real time and to your point i think
being willing to have
foresight planning because that really
is the only way to have sanity i think
as an entrepreneur plus
lifestyle and uh not let your business
take total control of your life but at
the same time we also got to be willing
to react and pivot in real time and so
in just a second i want to kind of talk
about maybe some factors you can't
control it doesn't surprise me that as
you know the entrepreneur that you are
the business that you've built that you
basically took extreme ownership for
your channel being messed up you're like
here's what i could have done better and
just to recap for listeners again your
views might be down because
the rawness of your content is that you
originally started with has become
overproduced your views could be down
maybe because you're trying to fix stuff
that isn't broken maybe you're
overbatched so you're not as in touch
with your audience um and you're not
reacting to real-time trends or
real-time pain points or you're just
you're kind of like in a way robotically
making content as opposed to really
being connected at that real time quick
moving heart level
however the truth is vanessa i think
there's also you know
external factors that could have played
a part in this or certainly also
apply to those that might be like i'm i
feel like i'm doing everything right i'm
not making
any of those quote unquote mistakes
do you think
seasons come in you've been on youtube a
couple years
summer versus you know fall
i think the pandemic um the viewership
high caused by the pandemic lockdown is
actually worn off and a lot of creators
are having withdrawals because
they they were like all of a sudden
everyone was locked down they're like my
views are up and they may be attributed
too much credit to themselves
because
people were just and now they're back at
work to a degree and so sometimes there
are external factors and we can't
control those but what are maybe some
that could be causing viewership to go
down have you ever noticed on your
channel seasons react differently to
your videos what are some insights
100 just basically everything you said
like what i also realized too was um
seasonality you know and i love how you
mentioned covid like
and you kind of like attributing all the
success to you like oh my gosh i'm
crushing it because i'm getting so many
views but then you realize like oh
everyone's locked down so they're
obviously watching more videos not just
mine but everyone else's um and so i do
think that in the summertime especially
in this like day and age after covid
where things are opening up again people
are thinking about traveling people are
thinking you know about future plans
there may be certain videos that they're
not watching right now versus let's say
if you are a travel like account maybe
your views might be up during this time
period right because it's summertime
people are planning or maybe people are
looking for like fashion advice on what
to wear in this season you know there's
going to be certain niches certain
industries that may have um more views
on some seasons versus others i find
that you have to also think about like
human psychology and human behavior in
general um so even for me like yes i
take extreme ownership on where i fell
short in my channel and i always try not
to blame the algorithm or not blame
external factors but i do also recognize
that it was summertime and especially
after the pandemic like i mentioned
people just not necessarily watching
these like my type of videos as much
versus them thinking about traveling and
all that or maybe even like something
that's really well known that we all
know about is during christmas time or
the holidays like
and if you're monetized usually that's
where
you might make a little bit more money
because there's more people watching
videos during the holidays especially
when they're cozied in and they have
time off from work or the fact that
there's advertisers that might pay more
uh to have their ads shown during the
holidays because people are in a
shopping season and so there are
different um seasonalities that can
affect your channel and you shouldn't
necessarily 100 blame yourself and think
that you're the worst creator ever uh
you do want to look at those things and
another thing too i like how you
mentioned the fact that you know you
talk to other creators that's something
that i like to use as a benchmark
because you know sometimes it's like
okay am i just so am i the problem like
am i the one that's really like
struggling here and maybe i just need to
up my content or maybe i need to like
refresh something or is it just how it
is for everyone and so what i like to do
is maybe i'll look at channels like
yours or channels like you know
other people who share similar content
to me and i look at hey are their views
down what's going on like what can i
actually see is happening on their
channel now if i'm doing that and i'm
seeing everyone else in my industry
except myself have skyrocketed views all
the you know all the vanity metrics or
whatever else higher engagement all
those things and i'm gonna say to myself
okay i should probably look at what i'm
doing wrong because if there's
opportunities for other people to win
i gotta look at what i can improve
versus it's a different sentiment where
i'm looking at everyone else and i'm
like oh okay well i'm seeing similar
trends that's happening to their account
so maybe it's not just me and that's
maybe an opportunity where you'd want to
reach out to other creators swap notes
kind of like what we're doing right now
or you can just kind of make your own
assumptions on what you see happening
with other people in your industry
yeah and i'm curious vanessa if you're
like me
you know i know we try to
not tie our identity to this stuff but
have you ever noticed that your emotions
uh can sometimes be connected to your
youtube analytics i know for me
uh we say go for green in our community
and you mentioned looking at your
analytics it's all red arrows it's all
dropping down and what's sometimes hard
i was talking to another creator who's
also kind of in this slump and really
introspective like not even and by the
way not a slump this creator it just
grew 19 000 subscribers in a month just
got 1.5 billion million views in a month
but is down about 20
from the month before
and the conclusion there or at least the
emotional illogical conclusion is man
what am i doing wrong what's going on
now as a business owner we can't afford
not to say oh my gosh 20
drop
is there external factors internal
factors what can we do is this if this
is an ongoing trend that would
eventually lead us to you know total
decline so you can't be asleep at the
wheel
building you know as a youtube
entrepreneur a content entrepreneur but
nevertheless
19 000 new subscribers in 28 days and
1.5 million views is so insane i'm sure
a ton of people listening to the podcast
right now that's that's like their dream
target you know that's what they're
praying for and this individual is
living it but
man when you you it's almost like the
way that youtube presents analytics to
you can almost be toxic because it's
like keep it going man like and you
still if you just look at the math think
media has just lately said as usual
every month we've been like same as
usual same as usual and that's about 25
000 new subscribers on our main channel
every month which is freaking
insane
but it's like yeah you're doing all
right mike's just so it's just average
bro it's just average so i don't know
sometimes
i can get in my mind and in my in my
feels you know like about man is this a
reflection what's wrong and and i don't
know have you how do you handle
this hitting your emotions are you able
to just disconnect or does it sometimes
are you laying in bed thinking about
like man what's going on with my youtube
channel like am i okay is this a
reflection on my worth as a human like
you ever go through any of this uh
emotional rollercoaster
of course i think i think anyone does
and i think as a creator
like what you put out in the internet is
almost like an extension of you
and when you see youtube creator studio
telling you hey your channel's not doing
that great
you you do make it mean about yourself
and i think that having that
self-awareness is really important um
that it doesn't dictate who you are and
i love the fact and you actually like i
love that like how you said yeah even
though on the creator studio youtube is
giving you those red
down arrows and whatever else or saying
that you're just average you have to
realize that there's still a lot of like
20 even if you get 25 views like it's 25
people
that have watched your videos and i
think that's something that you should
be proud of and i also think that
success is relative too
right like
oftentimes we get caught up maybe even
comparing ourselves to like other people
who have bigger channels or whatever all
the fanciness kind of like how i did and
i got caught up in that and i thought
okay well i'm not doing good enough
because they've got all this and i've
got a up my equipment game and i've got
to do all those things and i got
negative results from doing that and
that was all me acting on emotion
because i saw the reds
it wasn't me actually just being like
okay well let's be objective about this
let's take a step back
i will look at the analytics but only my
analytics and compare what i could what
i can actually control right like if the
click-through rate is
like down maybe less than three percent
or like less than what i usually get
okay easy let's think objectively let's
look at let let's let's try something
let's a b test something maybe i i get a
plug-in like vid iq or tubebuddy and a b
test two thumbnails you know and be
objective about it and collect the data
and just realize that i'm only in
in competition with myself i just want
to be better than maybe i was yesterday
and i can only control this many things
on my channel and i'm doing the best
that i can and i think that that's
what's important um at the end of the
day when you're a content creator you're
just gonna drive yourself mad at that
point if you're if you're constantly
tying your self-worth to this type of
stuff
well i hope that conversation left you
with something to think about and i want
to ask you what is your next action step
i really loved how real vanessa was in
this interview where she talked about
how she let how she felt about her
channel guide what she did and honestly
it came back to being data driven that
started to be the piece that she used to
make decisions and i can so fall into
this trap as well when i think about my
action step after listening to this it's
that i think sometimes this needs to be
perfect just like vanessa
stumbled through over time feeling like
it needed to be better and better and
better more produced i fall into the
same trap i even did this here on the
podcast sometimes it's harder when i
think about the lights and the camera
and the microphone and am i wearing the
right outfit is my makeup right is this
highly produced what does this look like
and honestly people just want real they
just want you and she said her best
performing videos were the ones she was
making when she lived at home with her
mom in her bedroom that's honestly all
you really have to do the content will
win and i am even a testament to this as
well one of my best performing videos
right now on think media that i filmed
this year is actually the worst
looking video it's like i shot it on a
baked potato it was my webcam it was
poorly lit i was positioned wrong but
the content is what is winning and i
just want to encourage you that if you
feel like you just can't get started
because you don't have the right camera
or you just can't get started because
you don't like the way you look or you
just can't get started because you don't
have the right background that you need
to put those things to rest and just
press record your first videos they're
gonna be your worst videos and so you
need to get those out of the way now and
people really do just want you they want
the message that you have they want the
strategies that you're going to give
them they want you to help them solve
that problem so let's get rid of the
facade that it has to be perfect and if
you're ready to jump in and get your
first 1000 subscribers if you're ready
to jump in and understand that there's a
mindset that goes to youtube that there
is strategy that goes to youtube then
you need to pick up the holiday bundle
at
thinkmediasale.com where we're helping
you get to your first 1000 subscribers
your first 1 000 subscribers and beyond
that's at thinkholidaysale.com
and if you are a loving this type of
content i want you to hit like over on
youtube if you're over there and if
you're listening on itunes would you do
me a solid and just write and review
this podcast it would mean the world to
me if you could go over there and leave
a review and let us know what you think
about the show every single week i love
to feature someone on the podcast and
today it's lavatron lavatron says great
for insight and motivation thank you
sean heater heater wow my name is
heather and the think team
you guys give us so much knowledge and
insight on ways to keep our channels
going and growing i remember first
getting to know you all during one of
the free youtube challenge courses last
year you guys inspired me to get into
the right mindset to finally commit to
my channel oh my goodness i could read
these all day long not because you're
saying thank you to us but because you
took the step you are doing the work and
you're showing up for your audience so
excited for you and thank you for rating
and reviewing the podcast well thank you
so much for being a part of today's
episode we're going to feature vanessa
in next week's episode as well so stay
locked and loaded for part two of this
series did you see thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new youtube made simple
course bundle
get over 1 900
worth of our best courses tools
templates and more just go to
thinkmediasale.com
[Music]